how's James doing he's good he's really
good Khloe Kardashian started dating NBA
star James Harden in July 2015 but their
relationship was strained after her ex
Lamar Odom was hospitalized in October
on Thursday eet caught up with the 31
year old on the set of her new talk show
kocktails with khloé' how hard is that
to have a relationship with someone who
you're busy I mean you do a lot he's on
the road 24 set a tee two games a years
a lot yeah we make it work I mean I'm we
do make it work I'm someone who I do
like to put my relationships as a
priority and I tried to make I really
try to make that work work um and as
long as people are making the effort to
do so I think anything can work so it's
a lot of juggling time and balance but
I'm a really good multitasker and I just
know how to balance it out even if it's
just a 48 hour trip well as long as you
get that time in mm-hmm
then it works but also I think keeping
it a little private too has really
helped us yeah I just think it keeps
things I've learned from experience it
keeps things close to your heart I don't
know things a little private adult
mysteries good